c'est un communiqué russe du centre pour
la réconciliation des parties
belligérantes en syrie qui a confirmé
l'information des frappes aériennes
russes ont été menées ce jeudi sur des
positions terroriste high de l'ibpt le
20 février 2020 des bandits armés
terroristes ont perpétré plusieurs
attaques massives au moyen de nombreux
véhicules blindés contre des unités
gouvernementales en direction de mines
arabe à la demande du commandement
syrien
les avions sukhoï su 24 des forces
aérospatiale de russie ont effectué des
frappes sur les bandes armés terroristes
qui avaient réalisé une percée afin de
les empêcher de s'avancer à l'intérieur
du territoire syrien
sans donner de précisions sur ces raids
la porte parole de la diplomatie russe a
réaffirmé la coopération militaire mise
en place avec l'armée syrienne tout
d'abord vous ne devez pas oublier que
nous parlons d'un état souverain
les forces armées syriennes sont sur
leur territoire ce devrait être un
principe de base
bien sûr il y à la coopération existante
de la syrie avec les militaires russes
et venant d'autres pays
[Musique]
je pense que la communauté
internationale ne doit pas oublier le
principe de base selon ankara ses
frappes auraient tués deux soldats turcs
y en aurait blessé cinq autres
par ailleurs le ministère turc de la
défense déclare avoir éliminé 50 cibles
syriennes dans la région d'idlib
face à ces nouvelles violences l'union
européenne appelle à l'arrêt de
l'offensive militaire des forces de
damas dans la zone la nouvelle offensive
militaire du régime syrien et de ses
alliés à idlib qui provoque d'énormes
souffrances humaines est inacceptable
l'union européenne appelle tous les
acteurs à cesser immédiatement les
hostilités et demande instamment à
toutes les parties au conflit de
permettre un accès humanitaire directe
et sans entraves à tous ceux qui sont
dans le besoin
de leur côté la chancelière allemande et
le président français ont annoncé
vouloir rencontrer les chefs d'état
russe et turc pour trouver une solution
politique a aidé
[Musique]